les mesures de sécurité ont été
renforcées autour de l'ambassade de cuba
paris situé dans le 15e arrondissement
de la capitale le bâtiment a été visé
dans la soirée par des cocktails molotov
qu'ils ont provoqué des dégâts mineurs
l'attaqué a été condamnée par la france
la diplomatie cubaine dénonce elle une
attaque terroriste et accuse les états
unis écouté hier soir vers minuit des
individus ont lancé trois cocktails
molotov contre la façade de notre
ambassade de cuba en france il ya eu des
feux qui étaient à temps par notre
personnel les pompiers sont arrivés
quelques minutes plus tard les faits
étaient déjà à temps après évidemment la
police est arrivée et ils sont pris et
les déclarations nous avons montré toute
notre opération pour éclaircir ce qui
s'est passé quelques minutes après les
événements les ministres qui balaie ce
fait être à hier à la van a fait des
déclarations en dénonçant cet acte
terroriste contre l'ambassade de cuba en
france et un responsable hissant la
médiation des etats-unis qui avec la
politique d campagne permanente quitter
cuba encourage des personnes à commettre
ce type d'actions violentes contre des
installations à cuba et à l'étranger